a weekend political gathering will bring
together the largest group yet of 2020
Democratic presidential hopefuls 22 of
the 24 candidates will campaign in South
Carolina this weekend the Democratic
frontrunner former Vice President Joe
Biden will arrive in the middle of
growing scrutiny over race issues ed
O'Keefe is in Columbia South Carolina
with more on this story good morning to
you ad how important is this weekend for
all the candidates especially Joe Biden
Oh Gail this is a big one because South
Carolina has the largest contingency of
african-american voters in early primary
States and as you said it comes as Joe
Biden and some of his opponents are
sparring over issues regarding race the
former vice president is scheduled to
have meetings today with local
african-american leaders to discuss some
comments he made this week regarding his
past work with the late segregationist
Democratic senators James Eastland and
Herman Tallmadge Biden says he was
simply pointing out that you have to
work sometimes with people even though
you might disagree with them CBS News
has learned there's been another attempt
to ease the situation
just hours after Biden and his 2020
opponent New Jersey Senator Cory Booker
sparred publicly over the matter the two
spoke by phone late Wednesday multiple
people in both camps tell us call went
well and that the two men discussed
privately what they've been saying
publicly Biden clarified but didn't
apologize for his remarks Gail all right
thank you very much a toe cave voters in
South Carolina
responding to Biden what can you tell us
about that well just mixed views on the
situation with him some are familiar
with it others are not the best way to
gauge this let's play a bit of our
colleague Elaine Quijano of CBS n and
her conversation with some folks at a
Baptist Church here in Columbia who 50
years ago I mean had to deal with
segregation and Jim Crow laws Vice
President Biden seems to be genuine and
everything he's done up into his
political career but I mean he does have
a few hiccups I think his statement was
very insensitive and he does need to
make some type of public statement that
really backs up not only just his
personal feelings to say hey you know
what
I didn't mean it this way if he was
speaking in a sense I'm able to work
with others who share different opinions
and beliefs with me in order to get
things done for American people and for
the voters I don't see a problem with
that maybe just say that he may have was
he was just being a little insensitive
and expressed what he what he meant to
say now this weekend 22 of the 24
presidential contenders will be here for
events one of the more edible
interesting stops on the campaign trail
tonight is Congressman Jim Clyburn a
self-described world famous fish fry
organizers have spent the last few days
for praying 44 hundred pounds of fish
4,400 pounds of fish and 6,400 slices of
bread to feed thousands of Democratic
Party activists set to show up Gail it
promises to be a hot and tasty evening
healing foods thank you very much and
not mad at that at all thank you thank
you very much
our digital streaming channel that CBS n
will have complete coverage of the fish
fry tonight beginning at 7:00 Eastern
6:00 central including to our special
red and blue and interviews with the
candidates and their campaigns fish fry
and bread you can rise special I love it
buy special don't forget the hot sauce
you can find CBS n it CBS news.com or
the CBS News